my name is Aryan my question is since  the flashback have been consistently -  five years ago and we're now in season  six are we going to be flash back to  season one  yeah basically how we're going to take  money we're going to give you a filthy  flashback it won't be every episode they  won't be serialize they'll be character  specific and I'll give you one example  we are you know mainly because I've been  like trying to figure out the right  opportunities to make this announcement  but as you saw the trailer Bonnie  Bennett is in fact for the season  premiere but he's also coming back for a  special two-part episode in the first  half of this season where we're really  going to be you know really focusing  hard on his character you know post  everything he's experienced on the show  and we you know intend to do a Slade  Wilson flashback story  [Applause]  you